You're juggling a lot, but you can still squeeze in a financial plan. With the Northwestern Mutual Financial Advisor as your partner, it's not only possible, it's personalized. So if you're tying the knot, closing on a house, or welcoming a little one, you'll be ready for whatever life tosses your way. It's the right time to feel less stressed and more certain. That's a better way to money. Let's get started at nm.com, the Northwestern Mutual Life Insurance Company, Milwaukee, Wisconsin. Although we don't have a complete national picture, data from a few states and cities are showing that the COVID-19 virus is disproportionately infecting and killing African Americans. In Illinois, for example, African Americans comprise 43% of people who have died from the disease and 28% of positive tests, even though there are only 15% of the state's population. Similarly, in Detroit, Milwaukee, North Carolina, Connecticut, South Carolina, African Americans are disproportionately.
您现在忙得不可开交，但仍可以挤出时间制定财务计划。有了西北互助人寿保险公司的理财顾问作为您的合作伙伴，这不仅是可能的，而且是量身定制的。因此，无论您是准备结婚、买房，还是迎接新生命，您都能为生活带来的任何挑战做好准备。现在是减少压力、增加确定性的好时机。这是一种更好的理财方式。让我们从 nm.com 开始，西北互助人寿保险公司，威斯康星州密尔沃基。虽然我们还没有全国范围的完整情况，但来自一些州和城市的数据显示，新冠病毒对非裔美国人的感染和致死率不成比例地高。例如，在伊利诺伊州，非裔美国人占该州死亡病例的 43%，占阳性检测病例的 28%，尽管他们仅占该州人口的 15%。同样，在底特律、密尔沃基、北卡罗来纳州、康涅狄格州、南卡罗来纳州，非裔美国人也受到了不成比例的影响。
at risk. Why is this so? And what can we do to alleviate these skewed proportions as we work together to flatten the curve and beat back this pandemic? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Most media reports of these inequities suggest that African Americans are at higher risk than other populations because of a higher incidence of underlying chronic medical conditions such as diabetes in hypertension, and because African-Americans are less likely to have health insurance or a regular health care provider. While these factors may be true, this analysis overlooks the root causes of the African-American health gap, historic and contemporary racism and discrimination. Here to talk about
处于危险之中。为什么会这样？在我们共同努力拉平曲线并击退这场大流行病时，我们能做些什么来缓解这些扭曲的比例？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。大多数关于这些不平等的媒体报道认为，非裔美国人比其他群体面临更高的风险，是因为他们患有糖尿病和高血压等潜在慢性疾病的比例更高，而且非裔美国人不太可能拥有医疗保险或固定的医疗服务提供者。虽然这些因素可能是事实，但这种分析忽略了非裔美国人健康差距的根本原因：历史和当代的种族主义与歧视。
these issues and what psychology can do about them is Dr. Brian Smedley, APA's chief of psychology in the public interest. In this post, Dr. Smedley leads APA's efforts to apply the science and practice of psychology to the fundamental problems of human welfare and social justice. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Smedley. Thanks for having me, Kim. My first question to you, as we began to see the disparate impact of COVID-19 on African Americans in places like Chicago, New Orleans, and the other locations I mentioned a moment ago, were you surprised?
在这里讨论这些问题以及心理学能做些什么的是美国心理学会公共利益心理学主管布莱恩·斯梅德利博士。在这个职位上，斯梅德利博士领导美国心理学会致力于将心理学的科学和实践应用于人类福利和社会正义的基本问题。欢迎来到《心理学谈话》，斯梅德利博士。谢谢你的邀请，金。我的第一个问题是，当我们开始看到新冠病毒在芝加哥、新奥尔良和我刚才提到的其他地方对非裔美国人造成的不平等影响时，您感到惊讶吗？
Unfortunately, I'm not. Epidemics and pandemics historically have hit our most vulnerable and marginalized populations hardest. We know this from past epidemics. And in the U.S. context, of course, African Americans have faced generations of systemic discrimination and racism, as you pointed out. So the fact that African Americans have higher rates of chronic health conditions to begin with is in itself a reflection of that social and economic inequality. And so pandemics such as COVID-19 are going to spread most rapidly among those populations that are most vulnerable and have been, in fact, marginalized historically. So unfortunately, we could have predicted that this would happen.
不幸的是，我并不感到惊讶。从历史上看，流行病和大流行病总是对我们最脆弱和边缘化的群体打击最大。我们从过去的流行病中就知道了这一点。当然，在美国的背景下，正如您所指出的，非裔美国人几代人以来一直面临着系统性的歧视和种族主义。因此，非裔美国人本身就患有更高比例的慢性健康疾病，这本身就是这种社会和经济不平等的反映。因此，像新冠病毒这样的大流行病将在那些最脆弱且在历史上确实被边缘化的群体中传播得最快。所以不幸的是，我们本可以预见到这种情况会发生。
And as the epidemic continues to spread, we can predict that other populations that have faced historic discrimination and marginalization will also experience higher rates of spread of the virus. Are we seeing some of that already? I've read that some of the rates. among the Latino community are also out of proportion. Yes, and there are a number of factors that contribute, of course, to the spread of the virus in these populations. You look at living conditions where people may not be able to practice physical distancing. You look at the kinds of work that people of color are disproportionately in,
随着疫情继续蔓延，我们可以预见，其他面临历史性歧视和边缘化的群体也将经历更高比例的病毒传播。我们已经看到这种情况了吗？我读到一些关于拉丁裔社区的感染率也超出了比例。是的，当然有许多因素导致了病毒在这些群体中的传播。看看人们可能无法进行物理距离隔离的生活条件，看看有色人种不成比例地从事的工作类型，
sectors where they might be considered essential workers, or don't have the economic luxury of being able to stay home, rather than going out and working, housing conditions, conditions in neighborhoods, all of these factors may contribute to the spread of the virus. And it's important to note that in many cases, these are environmental conditions, but the residents of those neighborhoods have very little control over, such as the presence of environmental pollutants. There's some new research, for example, suggesting that in neighborhoods with a higher concentration of air pollution, that the COVID-190, virus is spreading more rapidly. And you can see how that might be the case, given the fact that
在那些他们可能被认为是必要工作人员的行业，或者没有经济条件能够待在家里而不是出去工作，住房条件，社区环境，所有这些因素都可能导致病毒的传播。值得注意的是，在许多情况下，这些是居民几乎无法控制的环境条件，例如环境污染物的存在。例如，一些新的研究表明，在空气污染浓度较高的社区，新冠病毒传播得更快。考虑到以下事实，你可以看出为什么会这样：
respiratory illnesses are more often linked with air pollution and other sources of environmental degradation. What about immigration status? How is that playing into the infection rates in those communities? Yes. And so this is a complex issue that, again, complicates our ability to flatten the curve, to contain the spread of the virus. There are many. new arrivals to our country. Some are legal immigrants. Some are folk who are here without documentation. Of course, among those without documentation, there's a fear of ICE intervention and detainment deportation. So you can see how individuals who are here without documentation might be fearful of coming forward if they're symptomatic, or they might be fearful of getting
呼吸道疾病通常与空气污染和其他环境退化源有关。移民身份呢？这在这些社区的感染率中起什么作用？是的。这是一个复杂的问题，再次使我们拉平曲线、遏制病毒传播的能力变得复杂。我国有很多新移民。有些是合法移民。有些是没有证件的人。当然，在没有证件的人群中，人们担心移民及海关执法局的干预、拘留和驱逐。所以你可以看出，没有证件的人如果出现症状，可能会害怕站出来，或者他们可能会害怕让
relatives tested who might be symptomatic. But even among folk who are here legally, among legal immigrants, the fact that the administration has taken steps to curtail their use of or access to public benefits such as safety net programs for fear that that might be detrimental when applying for permanent legal residency, that kind of fear can also suppress the ability or willingness of folk, even among legal immigrants, to access testing or other public health services or public benefits that might be otherwise helpful to them. Do you think that the historic mistrust of organized medicine among some black people, especially older black people, is playing a role in this?
有症状的亲属接受检测。但即使在合法移民中，政府采取措施限制他们使用或获得公共福利（如社会安全网计划）的事实，也因为担心这可能会在申请永久合法居留权时产生不利影响，这种恐惧也会抑制人们（即使是合法移民）获得检测或其他公共卫生服务或可能对他们有帮助的公共福利的能力或意愿。您认为一些黑人，尤其是年长的黑人，对有组织医疗机构的历史性不信任在其中起作用吗？
Well, the mistrust issue is a complex one. Certainly there is mistrust among some segments. But I think a broader issue is the fact that people of color, African Americans in particular, are very aware of the research showing that they often receive a lower quality of care than white patients, even when they're presenting with the same illnesses, the same kinds of health insurance, and sometimes even in the same health systems. So the fact that there are disparities in health care and the quality of care for these populations may be playing a larger role than the issue of mistrust itself. I think all of these factors, of course, are things that our health care systems need to actively address. And so when we allow this kind of fear to persist, what it does is it increases risk for all of us, if some of our communities are left vulnerable.
嗯，不信任问题是一个复杂的问题。当然，在某些群体中确实存在不信任。但我认为一个更广泛的问题是，有色人种，特别是非裔美国人，非常清楚研究表明，即使在患有相同疾病、拥有相同医疗保险、甚至在相同的医疗系统中，他们获得的护理质量往往也低于白人患者。因此，这些群体在医疗保健和护理质量方面存在差异的事实，可能比不信任问题本身发挥了更大的作用。我认为所有这些因素当然都是我们的医疗系统需要积极解决的问题。因此，当我们任由这种恐惧持续存在时，如果我们的某些社区被置于脆弱境地，它就会增加我们所有人的风险。
Is there some impact from basically the reticence of some people to even get tested? I mean, I think we know from the HIV epidemic that there are a lot of people who said, I don't even want to know. I won't get tested because what can I do about it? Is that playing into it as well? That may be the case. Certainly we know that in the early days of the HIV epidemic, because it was often a death sentence that certainly people felt a loss of control,
有些人甚至拒绝接受检测，这是否有影响？我的意思是，我认为我们从艾滋病毒流行中知道，有很多人说，我甚至不想知道。我不会去检测，因为我能做什么呢？这也在其中起作用吗？情况可能确实如此。当然，我们知道在艾滋病毒流行的早期，因为它通常被视为死刑，所以人们确实感到失去了控制，
even if they knew their status. But nonetheless, it's important, of course, to no one status, whether we're talking about COVID-19 or HIV. The other challenge, of course, though, with the issue of stigma in testing is that some populations who may be at heightened risk may not even be offered testing. So the issue of bias and stigma goes both ways. On the one hand, there may be stigmatized populations may fear getting tested, but on the other hand, those health professionals who are charged with determining where these tests are being applied, because remember, there aren't enough tests at present to address the needs of the population, or at least those who might be symptomatic, they are making decisions about who gets testing. And again, we know from a large body of research that, unfortunately, patients of color are less likely to get evidence-based or recommended interventions, possibly including testing based on their identity status and stereotypes and biases, even unconscious biases that health professionals may hold.
即使他们知道自己的状况。但尽管如此，了解自己的状况当然很重要，无论我们谈论的是新冠病毒还是艾滋病毒。当然，检测中污名化问题的另一个挑战是，一些可能处于高风险的群体甚至可能不会被提供检测。因此，偏见和污名化的问题是双向的。一方面，被污名化的群体可能害怕接受检测；但另一方面，那些负责确定这些检测应用地点的医疗专业人员（因为请记住，目前没有足够的检测来满足人口的需求，或者至少是那些可能有症状的人的需求），他们正在决定谁能接受检测。同样，我们从大量的研究中知道，不幸的是，有色人种患者不太可能获得基于证据或推荐的干预措施，这可能包括基于他们的身份地位和刻板印象以及偏见（甚至是医疗专业人员可能持有的无意识偏见）的检测。
Some of the messages that are being spread in minority communities and elsewhere, I mean, it's creeping into the media for certain. include that the coronavirus was created in a lab in the United States and it was sent to China, that this was all a plot. There is also a president and others who are hyping untested medications. What's the psychological impact of hearing this kind of information and how can people sort out the scientific facts from misapprehensions or even in some cases outright falsehoods? Right. Yeah, you're touching on an issue that's critically important in the pandemic response. It's vitally important that everyone have accurate scientific information about what they can do to reduce their risk, what they should do if they're symptomatic, and what they should do to help their families and their communities. And so certainly we know that misinformation is more likely to spread when people are fearful, when people are anxious, and when people are uncertain.
在少数族裔社区和其他地方传播的一些信息，我的意思是，它确实正在渗入媒体，包括新冠病毒是在美国的一个实验室制造的，并被送往中国，这一切都是一个阴谋。还有总统和其他人正在炒作未经测试的药物。听到这类信息的心理影响是什么？人们如何从误解甚至在某些情况下是彻头彻尾的谎言中理清科学事实？对。是的，你触及了一个在大流行应对中至关重要的议题。每个人都获得关于他们可以采取什么措施来降低风险、如果出现症状应该做什么、以及应该做什么来帮助他们的家庭和社区的准确科学信息，这一点至关重要。因此，我们当然知道，当人们感到恐惧、焦虑和不确定时，错误信息更容易传播。
And that is certainly the psychological state of much of the population during this pandemic. So that's why it's so vitally important that our elected officials and our public health leaders communicate clearly and in culturally excellent ways to reach all of our populations, providing the best scientific information so that people can trust what they're hearing. They can take action to reduce their risks. But when we have the opposite, when we have clear instances of missing, information, when people are not getting the facts, it only contributes more to the fear and anxiety. And those kinds of psychological states can make it harder to help reduce risk for many of our populations and ultimately flatten the curve. So clearly, the psychological dimensions of the pandemic are absolutely vital to address just as we do things like physical distancing.
这确实是这场大流行期间大部分人口的心理状态。这就是为什么我们的民选官员和公共卫生领导人以文化上卓越的方式进行清晰沟通，以触及我们所有的群体，提供最好的科学信息，以便人们能够信任他们所听到的内容，这一点至关重要。他们可以采取行动降低风险。但当我们有相反的情况时，当我们有明确的错误信息实例时，当人们没有得到事实时，它只会加剧恐惧和焦虑。而这些心理状态会使帮助我们许多群体降低风险并最终拉平曲线变得更加困难。因此，很明显，大流行的心理层面与我们所做的物理距离隔离等事情一样，绝对需要解决。
What are some of the possible solutions to these health inequities? What is APA and psychology asking our governments and the public to do? Absolutely. There are a number of steps that have to be taken. We know that it's essential that public health agencies conduct surveillance, collecting data to understand which populations are at risk. Where is the virus going? Where do we need to focus resources to help communities to manage their risk? So we've called on much more robust, standardized data collection. The federal government has a significant role to play in terms of providing resources and technical assistance to state and local health agencies who are often on the front lines of testing. But then ultimately, we need to coordinate all of the state and local and federal data collection
解决这些健康不平等的可能方案有哪些？美国心理学会和心理学界要求我们的政府和公众做什么？绝对有。必须采取许多步骤。我们知道，公共卫生机构进行监测、收集数据以了解哪些群体处于危险之中是至关重要的。病毒正在向哪里传播？我们需要在哪里集中资源来帮助社区管理他们的风险？因此，我们呼吁进行更稳健、标准化的数据收集。联邦政府在为往往处于检测第一线的州和地方卫生机构提供资源和技术援助方面可以发挥重要作用。但最终，我们需要协调所有州、地方和联邦的数据收集
into one comprehensive database. We only know that African Americans are higher at risk at higher risk because of the data collection and surveillance work that some states and localities are engaged in. We need all states and localities to have the resources, capacity, and a technical know-how to be able to do this. Unfortunately, over the past several decades, the public health infrastructure has been decimated by funding cuts at all levels, federal, state, and local, leaving us poorly prepared to deal with a pandemic, such as that which we're dealing with now. So what we need is a much more robust effort led by federal support and resources to help collect data. So data collection is a first step. A second thing that we have to do is to ensure that people have access to the services they need.
到一个综合数据库中。我们之所以知道非裔美国人处于更高风险中，是因为一些州和地方正在进行的数据收集和监测工作。我们需要所有州和地方都有资源、能力和技术诀窍来做到这一点。不幸的是，在过去的几十年里，公共卫生基础设施因各级（联邦、州和地方）的资金削减而遭到破坏，使我们准备不足以应对像我们现在正在处理的这样的大流行病。因此，我们需要在联邦支持和资源的领导下，做出更强有力的努力来帮助收集数据。所以数据收集是第一步。我们必须做的第二件事是确保人们能够获得他们需要的服务。
Health care obviously is a critically important service, but mental and behavioral health care are critically important as well, particularly for vulnerable populations that may be at higher risk and face a host of other sorts. of stress and other kinds of psychosocial stressors. So addressing the health and mental health needs of communities is critically important as well. And we can do that by doing things like expanding health and safety net programs. States that have expanded Medicaid, for example, are much better prepared and equipped to handle the crush of coronavirus cases that they're experiencing. But beyond that, we have to ultimately address the upstream factors, the root causes of health and equities that we see across racial and ethnic groups, across groups with different levels of income and education, across groups who are arriving here from different locations from around the globe.
医疗保健显然是一项至关重要的服务，但心理和行为健康护理也同样至关重要，特别是对于可能处于更高风险并面临其他各种压力和心理社会压力源的弱势群体而言。因此，解决社区的健康和心理健康需求也至关重要。我们可以通过扩大医疗和社会安全网计划等方式来做到这一点。例如，扩大了医疗补助计划的州在应对他们正在经历的新冠病毒病例激增方面准备得更充分、装备更完善。但除此之外，我们最终必须解决上游因素，即我们在不同种族和族裔群体、不同收入和教育水平群体、以及从全球不同地点来到这里的群体中看到的健康不平等的根本原因。
Addressing those inequities requires understanding the social, economic, and environmental determinants of health. I mentioned earlier that there are some neighborhoods that are experiencing higher rates of air pollution and that there may be, there's some indication that those communities may experience a higher incidence of infection with coronavirus. Well, those also happen to be neighborhoods that are disproportionately people of color, disproportionately low income. So addressing ultimately the factors that expose some neighborhoods to greater. risk, things like neighborhood poverty concentration, addressing sources of environmental degradation, improving sources of nutrition for these neighborhoods. Many of them are so-called food deserts, lacking access to healthy food retail, which could help to build the necessary physical
解决这些不平等问题需要了解健康的社会、经济和环境决定因素。我之前提到过，有些社区正在经历更高水平的空气污染，并且有迹象表明这些社区可能会经历更高的新冠病毒感染率。嗯，这些社区恰好也是有色人种比例过高、低收入比例过高的社区。因此，最终解决那些使一些社区面临更大风险的因素，例如社区贫困集中、解决环境退化源、改善这些社区的营养来源。其中许多是所谓的“食物沙漠”，缺乏获得健康食品零售的机会，这本可以帮助建立必要的身体
capacity to fight off infection, and addressing other neighborhood amenities like parks and recreational facilities. It's interesting to see the disparity in terms of who is able to get out and exercise during this period of physical distancing and staying at home. Some neighborhoods enjoy access to parks, recreational facilities, other kinds of amenities that allow them to stay physically active, while many neighborhoods, particularly those that are characterized by high levels of poverty and disinvestment may lack access to those kinds of resources. which again help build community capacity to avoid risk for infection. A lot of these situations that you've just described are very entrenched in our society.
抵御感染的能力，并解决公园和娱乐设施等其他社区便利设施的问题。看到在这一物理距离隔离和居家期间，谁能够出去锻炼的差异是很有趣的。一些社区享有公园、娱乐设施和其他允许他们保持身体活跃的便利设施，而许多社区，特别是那些以高贫困水平和投资不足为特征的社区，可能缺乏获得这些资源的途径，这再次有助于建立社区能力以避免感染风险。你刚才描述的许多情况在我们的社会中根深蒂固。
They have existed for decades, and people have been complaining about food deserts and disparate pollution levels and so forth. What's different now? I mean, do we really have the willpower to change it? Are you feeling more hopeful? that somehow out of this pandemic will come the change that we need? I think pandemics and epidemics definitely expose inequities that we all need to be concerned about. Pandemics ultimately know no boundaries, right? We are all at risk, no matter what your race or ethnicity, your income, your education level.
它们已经存在了几十年，人们一直在抱怨食物沙漠和不同的污染水平等等。现在有什么不同？我的意思是，我们真的有改变它的意志力吗？你感到更有希望了吗？这场大流行病会带来我们需要的改变吗？我认为大流行病和流行病绝对暴露了我们都需要关注的不平等。大流行病最终没有界限，对吧？无论你的种族或族裔、收入、教育水平如何，我们都面临风险。
And so clearly, if some communities face higher risk, then we're going to be much more challenged to be able to contain the pandemic and flatten the curve. So I think people are starting to see that persistent social and economic inequality, persistent discrimination, persistent racism, and other kinds of destructive social hierarchies ultimately impede our ability to manage epidemics and pandemics and to promote good public health and mental health. So sadly, as tragic as this pandemic has been, Part of what it is signaling to the country is that our fates are deeply intertwined and we ignore the needs of our most vulnerable communities at our own peril.
因此很明显，如果一些社区面临更高的风险，那么我们将面临更大的挑战来遏制大流行病并拉平曲线。所以我认为人们开始看到，持续的社会和经济不平等、持续的歧视、持续的种族主义以及其他类型的破坏性社会等级制度，最终阻碍了我们管理流行病和大流行病以及促进良好公共卫生和心理健康的能力。所以可悲的是，尽管这场大流行病非常悲惨，但它向国家发出的信号的一部分是，我们的命运是紧密相连的，我们忽视最弱势群体的需求，后果自负。
How much has xenophobia played a role in what's happening in some of these minority communities? And what are you doing to counteract that? Sure. Unfortunately, again, because of fear, because of uncertainty, because people don't have. facts. It tends to engender stereotypes. It tends to create space for xenophobic attitudes and racist attitudes to creep into the public consciousness. And it's particularly troubling when leaders and elected officials use irresponsible language that fomens xenophobic feelings. The APA has called for our leaders to use responsible language, to call the virus what it is.
仇外心理在这些少数族裔社区发生的事情中起了多大作用？你们正在采取什么措施来抵消这一点？当然。不幸的是，同样是因为恐惧，因为不确定性，因为人们没有事实。它往往会滋生刻板印象。它往往会为仇外态度和种族主义态度渗入公众意识创造空间。当领导人和民选官员使用煽动仇外情绪的不负责任的语言时，这尤其令人不安。美国心理学会呼吁我们的领导人使用负责任的语言，称呼病毒的本来名称。
is COVID-19. There's no need to link it to a specific region of the country because all that does is it increases risk for people of Asian descent to be attacked, to be bullied with racist and xenophobic attacks, both in public spaces and in virtual spaces. The problem with that, again, is that it divides our communities. It makes it easier to blame an innocent victim rather than blaming the real culprit here, which is the virus itself. So what we know from psychological research is that communities that have come together that have found ways to solve their challenges, communities that have high levels of what we call collective efficacy, are those communities. that are going to rebound the quickest from the pandemic. It strongly suggests that even though we're physically distancing, it's social cohesion, social coming together,
是新冠病毒。没有必要将其与该国的特定地区联系起来，因为这只会增加亚裔被攻击、被种族主义和仇外攻击欺凌的风险，无论是在公共场所还是虚拟空间。再次，这样做的问题在于它分裂了我们的社区。这使得责怪无辜的受害者比责怪真正的罪魁祸首（即病毒本身）更容易。所以我们从心理学研究中知道，那些团结起来、找到解决挑战的方法、拥有我们所说的“集体效能”高水平的社区，就是那些
that's going to help us solve this problem. I happen to know that the APA recently sent a letter to the White House asking the federal government to take the lead on requiring states and localities to report race, ethnicity, and other demographic characteristics of the people who are infected with the coronavirus, as well as those who die from it. What's been the response? We've been very pleased with the response. People understand at all levels, federal, state, and local, that collecting this data is
最快从大流行病中恢复过来的社区。这强烈表明，即使我们正在进行物理距离隔离，也是社会凝聚力、社会团结，
essential to understanding who's been affected and where the virus is going. So we're very pleased. The White House Domestic Policy Council is seeking a meeting. We have elected officials on both sides of the aisle who are looking for solutions. And so certainly when it comes to things like data collection, We need to be very concerned about personal privacy and our federal laws protecting the privacy, the private health records of individuals. But in this instance, when we're facing a pandemic, we need coordinated federal, state,
这将帮助我们解决这个问题。我碰巧知道美国心理学会最近致信白宫，要求联邦政府带头要求各州和地方报告感染新冠病毒以及死于该病毒的人的种族、族裔和其他人口统计特征。反响如何？我们对反响非常满意。各级（联邦、州和地方）的人们都明白，收集这些数据是
and local action to understand who's being tested, who's being hospitalized. What kinds of treatments are they getting? Again, as I mentioned earlier, we have research showing that on average patients of color are less likely to get the kinds of medical interviews. interventions and services that are the gold standard for medicine. So unless we're collecting this data, we are not likely to see where there might be disparities that might be dangerous for all of us. So the APA is calling for a much better coordinated federal response.
了解谁受到了影响以及病毒正在向哪里传播的关键。所以我们非常高兴。白宫国内政策委员会正在寻求会面。我们有两党的民选官员都在寻找解决方案。因此，当然，当涉及到数据收集之类的事情时，我们需要非常关注个人隐私以及保护个人私人健康记录的联邦法律。但在这种情况下，当我们面临大流行病时，我们需要协调一致的联邦、州
We're looking to see if the private sector can get engaged, helping to apply tools like artificial intelligence, again, to model and understand where this virus is going. and spreading going forward. So we're certain that there's a short-term response that's necessary in terms of getting this data collected quickly and disseminated, and a longer-term response in terms of understanding how we coordinate the vast array of federal data sources that can give us a more complete picture on how to stop the virus. Well, Dr. Smedley, thank you so much for joining Speaking of Psychology today.
和地方行动，以了解谁正在接受检测，谁正在住院。他们正在接受什么样的治疗？同样，正如我之前提到的，我们有研究表明，平均而言，有色人种患者不太可能获得作为医学黄金标准的医疗干预和服务。因此，除非我们收集这些数据，否则我们不太可能看到哪里可能存在对我们所有人都有危险的差异。因此，美国心理学会正在呼吁采取更协调一致的联邦应对措施。
I think this has been very an interesting conversation. I appreciate the work that you're doing to try to flatten the curve and end this pandemic. Thank you so much, Kim. And for our listeners, if you have any comments or ideas that you want to share about our podcast, you can send an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spot. or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website and download all the episodes at www.
我们正在观察私营部门是否能够参与进来，帮助应用人工智能等工具，再次建模并了解这种病毒正在向哪里传播。因此，我们确信在快速收集和传播这些数据方面需要短期应对，而在了解我们如何协调可以为我们提供关于如何阻止病毒的更完整图景的庞大联邦数据源方面需要长期应对。好吧，斯梅德利博士，非常感谢您今天参加《心理学谈话》。
speakingof psychology.org. Thanks for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为这是一次非常有趣的对话。我很感谢您为拉平曲线和结束这场大流行病所做的工作。非常感谢你，金。对于我们的听众，如果您对我们的播客有任何想分享的评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起，at APA.org。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。您也可以访问我们的网站并下载所有剧集，网址是 www.speakingofpsychology.org。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。